we're now 70 years embedded in assuming
the use of military power is the form of
American exceptionalism and leadership
hi I'm Nicolas way with reason TV and
today we are talking with Gordon Adams
he's an emeritus professor of
International Studies from American
University thanks for talking to us
thanks for having let's talk a bit about
the overseas contingency operation
budget talk a little bit about where
that comes from particularly in a 21st
century contact president george w bush
when he first invaded iraq realized that
the Department of Defense's existing
budget was not going to be adequate to
fund a force of 250,000 people in Iraq
and whatever residual about 30,000 I
think we had at the time in Afghanistan
and so they came up with a supplemental
budget now that's not unusual in other
war times first year or two we always go
up and say well we didn't know they were
going to do it and need some extra money
and we didn't count on it and Congress
help us out normal normal budgetary
behavior in Vietnam in Korea in any
other instance where we've done this
after two years you sort of say to the
Pentagon okay we're operating there this
is business as usual now you just gotta
build into your planning what it costs
to conduct this military operation right
Bush changed the precedent he didn't do
that he kept coming in with a
supplemental budget and the nice thing
about doing that was you could put it
into the hopper any time during the year
not when the budget had to go up for the
regular base budget of the Pentagon and
you knew that you didn't have to scrub
it as much either in the Pentagon or at
OMB in the White House or on capitol
hill because it was urgent it was
important was the troops in the field
you had to do it right so we got used
the Pentagon got used to this twofold
binary budget process where they plan
only a third base defense i watch it
which is all the people in the long-term
acquisition of equipment and the
overhead which is huge forty-five
percent of the Pentagon budgets overhead
right no private business would ever
accept that ratio but that's what we do
and then oh and here's the extra here's
the stuff for the warfighter well now
you know Pentagon civil servants and
Admirals and generals are no more stupid
than anybody else they figured out over
time this was great if you could go in
with something called an extra budget
for the troops and you couldn't get some
of the stuff you wanted in the regular
budget while let's put in the extra
budget for the toast the OCIO budget the
overseas contingency operations budget
is supposed to deal with okay it's going
directly to people in the field you know
on the battle lines in Iraq it's for
fighting the war what what else was
going into that that had nothing to do
with all kinds of things such as well
such as for example back in the early
20th century the army had decided quite
separate from war that it wanted to
restructure from divisions two brigades
armies always had divisions army was
saying well we need to move smaller
groups of people so we need you know an
autonomous operable Brigade structure
for the army and so they migrated to
that Brigade construct all the costs of
migrating were put in the OCO budget
which was then the supplemental rather
than in the base budget although this is
a base operation the army this is
particularly an army problem the army
bought a lot more striker vehicles than
they had planned to buy because they
could put a bunch of them in the
overseas contingency operation budget
they took the entire tank inventory of
m1a2 tanks and converted them to a
modern version in the overseas
contingency operation budget in other
words they were putting in constantly
things that belonged in base planning
for the Pentagon into this extra money
ostensibly for the forces you
characterize this as a slush fund
totally yeah so what happened recently I
mean you know where we're out of Iraq
we're supposed to already be out of
Afghanistan but we will eventually said
there should be a total drawdown of the
OCIO and and financially there was the
overseas contingency operation account
which is the name the Obama
administration gave to it you know post
supplementals that ocio account was as
high as a hundred eighty seven billion
dollars one year from we were at the
height of the Iraq surge it's now in the
50 to 60 billion dollar range right so
it did come down but because we have
pulled virtually everybody out of
Afghanistan and Iraq there's no way
we're spending 50 to 60
the in dollars on operation 260 billion
dollars just put that in perspective
that's basically the State Department's
complete budge the entire foreign policy
budget of the United States state a ID
all the trade agencies etc is about
fifty two billion dollars so that one
oko budget for the military which is a
less than ten percent of their whole
budget is in fact as big as all of our
foreign policy investment what is the
effect of having a kind of standing
slush fund on top of regular defense
budget well what effect does that have a
completely destroys budget discipline I
mean the bottom line here and i'll put
my beanie on for a moment from a budget
yours point of view saying there's
always more money simply conveys the
message to the department you don't have
to make choices you can always find a
way to raise the money for the things
that you want to do right we saw this
previously at the beginning of the
reagan administration because over a
two-year period reagan added over 50
billion dollars to the defense budget
the regular defense budget people in the
Pentagon were reaching in desk drawers
and pulling out dusted projects that
they hadn't gotten fund and say oh boy
we got to spend fifty two billion more
dollars what do we do that's the kind of
thing that happens today there's no
discipline so noted laces get made this
is despite the specter a couple years
ago of sequestration which went into
effect because neither Republicans or
Democrats could come up with a budget
that didn't really put a crimp in
frankly frankly all of the Congressional
Budget Office and general government
accountability office research since
that happened in 2013 as shown the
Pentagon sailed through it Mikey well
what's the likelihood that you know at
this time in a year that we will see an
overseas contingency operation budget
that's been drawn down to reflect our
diminished set of wars overseas I think
the prospect is zero I worked in the OMB
transition team in 2009 we wrote a deal
before Obama took office with the
Pentagon to limit the things that could
be covered in the OCO account so be very
strictly defined if you lost equipment
in Iraq you could replace that piece of
equipment if you had this much
additional in salaries you had to pay
because hazardous duty pay or combat pay
those could go in the yoko budget
nothing else everything else
to be in the base OMB has tried since
2010 budget to phase out oko we're about
to go forward with the 2017 so that's
eight budgets later we still have a
sixty billion dollar oko account or
budget it's not really an account it's a
budget at the Pentagon and the
Comptroller the Pentagon said last month
that it was pretty clear they were going
to leave office without having abolished
the OCO account and migrated to the base
is there any chance I mean people like
Rand Paul in the Republican Party and
Bernie Sanders have talked about
applying an audit process to the
Department of Defense is that worth
doing is it likely to shed light in a
way that would actually reform defense
spending a lot of people argue very
vigorously for auditing in the Pentagon
and indeed the Pentagon is supposed to
meet federal financial accounting
standards by 2017 that's the latest
promised by the vocal bhama
administration is to make it by then
that was Leon Panetta who is that that
goal when he was secretary of defense
they won't make it it's a huge complex
organism that does more than 20 million
contracting actions a year has over two
million people between active and
reserves in the military 800,000 people
civilians working for it and 700,000
contractor individual contractor service
personnel working for this is a massive
organism all the audit is really going
to tell you is when the congress
appropriated X dollars for x purpose did
it actually gets spent on x purpose
right and that's useful knowledge it's
not going to reform the way the Pentagon
does business so what if anything can be
done to you know reform the Pentagon
culture about spend it and in the
dollars will flow and then also how do
we pull if foreign policy should lead
and defense defense policies should
follow right what has to happen for that
to be kind of
well is on the first question you know
how do we form the Pentagon and its
practices it's tremendously hard and the
one thing that matters most has two
things really that matter most one is
cut their budget because nothing focuses
the attention of a teenager better than
losing their allowance so budget cuts
lead to reform they have in the past
they will in the future and to
leadership in the building itself at the
very top persistent devoted leadership
to the issue of controlling the way the
money gets spent because they have to
cut the overhead we can have a smaller
force and still do what we need to do
militarily they have to control the cost
of hardware programs they got runaway
pension and health care costs they got
all these things that aren't being
managing when you've got too much money
you don't have to manage them so solving
the reform problem means cutting the
budget and having leadership that's
committed to cutting the budget right
which is why the kinds of things that
Paul says or that Sanders said make a
lot of sense because it's a way of
imposing discipline how you change this
bigger cultural relationship between
force and foreign policy is very very
tough because we're now 70 years
embedded in assuming the use of military
power is the form of American
exceptionalism and leadership
internationally and breaking that
connection and saying our leadership
really depends on our economic strength
on our cultural strength on our
diplomacy and on the capacity to call
upon the military in service of our
goals when you need it we're going to
have to start thinking differently from
the way we thought for 70 years that's a
real uphill battle we've been talking to
Gordon Adams he's an emeritus professor
from American University thanks so much
for speaking with us pleasure for reason
TV I'm Nicholas B
you